hey everyone it's Mike from motor here
and welcome back to my channel I'm glad
you can join me for today's video we're
going to be talking about one of my uh
you know original and favorite trade
setups I still look for today in the
orderflow footprint chart now before I
jump in if you enjoy learning from my
videos don't forget to subscribe and
click that notification Bell so you
don't miss any new uploads you know it's
been a while since I've uploaded U some
videos but I'm finally feeling healthy
again I'm getting back into the groove
so you know you want to be notified when
I do Post new videos so if you find
today's video helpful be sure to hit
that like button for me and leave a
comment sharing your biggest takeaway I
do love hearing your feedback I do read
them sometimes I do rep to them and make
videos off them so your support really
does go a long way in helping me create
more videos just like this all right so
if you're getting value be sure to tap
the Subscribe button and let's grow
together all right so let's jump into
today's topic you know when I first
started uh trading with orderflow um you
know on a footprint chart that is there
there were certain things that I looked
for and you know as my trading sort of
progressed as a retail Trader I used to
work on the institutional side right I I
spent a lot of years at investment Banks
and trading firms um then after I sort
of semi retired and then eventually
fully
retired I would watch the market but you
know when I was watching the market on
normal bar chart you know something was
missing then when I found the footprint
chart I was like oh you know this is
exactly what I needed and there are
certain things that I always look for on
a plain footprint chart and this is
something you can do no matter what type
of footprint chart you're looking at as
long as you got the volume trade on the
bid the volume trade on the offer it's
something that you'll see time and time
again and when I did uh sort of move
into the software business right when we
created the orderflows trader software
this was one of the original tools that
we put in the the software and again I
got into the software business because I
created the software for my own trading
right and then other Traders saw it and
wanted copies that's how I got into the
software bus I didn't set out to uh
create the software uh with the main
purpose of of selling it it was really a
tool to help my own trading and it's
what we call we used to call single
prints uh we changed the name years ago
to exhaustion prints because what
happens in the market when the market
gets exhausted right think about it like
this right you're running you say you
got to run to um catch a bus or
something and you know you're
running you're you're trying to catch it
and you get tired right you you got to
slow down right and that's what happens
in the market you know eventually you
stop running because you got to catch
your breath and Market's the same way
Right Moves going up you know generally
have a lot of strength early on in the
market but as they get up near the top
and as moves tend to end there you know
people can lose interest in buying it at
higher prices okay and same thing with
moves Down Right Moves down and when the
last seller has sold think of it that
way moves up and when the last buyer has
bought moves down and when the last
seller has sold but it doesn't
necessarily have to come at um ends of
moves it can happen sometimes in the
middle of moves and today there's a
great example um in the snps okay so
this is just a plain one minute chart
people always ask me what's the best
chart for trading well it's really the
chart that helps you understand what
you're looking at in the order flow okay
and around 925 to about 940 we're going
sideways right we're trading basically
between uh 47 A2 I'll just draw a line
here and basically 50 and A2 you know
right here okay then the market broke
and went down to new lows right it broke
about 10 points within a matter of five
six minutes and if you're watching the
order flow the order flow is kind of
normal going through here but what was
unique about this is right before it
started breaking out you saw a sign
of Traders no longer interested in
trading around the 4950 level okay and
and people say well how can you see that
well what I look for when I'm looking at
the order flow right is how it trading
around the edges of bars okay so here
right we have a red
candle what I'm interested one of the
areas of that has my most interest is
right up here at the top right because
why is that interesting to me well the
market reversed right it traded up and
then it closed lower in a red candle
that's how red candles uh form right the
market often will open up generally will
trade higher now again it could open on
its
high and then get slammed and closes
lower that happens in every red candle a
green candle is the opposite right it
opens usually goes a little bit lower
then goes up closes higher than where it
opened so on the red candle what am I
interested in I'm interested in what's
happening at the top of the bar not
necessarily at the bottom of the bar
just as on a green candle I'd be
interested in what's happening at the
bottom of the bar right is there normal
volume going through or is there lack of
volume going through has the last Trader
bought or sold okay so in this area I'm
looking you know as just normal order
flow going through until you get to this
bar at 940 and you see a two here now
why is this relevant well we just traded
there a minute ago and you've been
trading there for the last 15 minutes
more or less and you can see traded 122
when it was bid traded 203 when it was
offered and then it comes into this bar
here right at 940 opens up at 49 and A4
trades up to 49 and 3/4 where we just
traded 203 on the offer but only two
contracts traded there and then the
market closed down so think about it
you're going sideways for 15
minutes then as you try to push
higher you you don't get sort of normal
order flow you don't get you know 100
200 you get two contracts one two that's
it a pair trade do you think Traders are
still interested in trying to get it to
go above 4950 they had been trying to
they'd get it above 4950 once twice
three times four times five times um
hits it here sixth time now on the
seventh time maybe the seventh time is
the charm it's not Traders aren't
interested anymore it trades two then it
closes down then it breaks and it sells
off 10 points this is what we call an
exhaustion print again now in the old
days when we first released the order
flow trador software we used to call it
a single print meaning there was single
um a single volume in the sense of a
number between one and nine um 10 would
be a double print but we've since it
renamed it years ago and we call it an
exhaustion print so it's just two now
that's all well and good but if you're
um watching a dome right this is why you
know people get into these stupid
semantic arguments oh a footprint chart
is not order flow it is it's orders that
go in and trade okay a dome is orders
that go in and sit on the bid and the
offer they're not trading is it
important that there's 184 down here at
uh 57 and a quarter yeah it is problem
is we're trading two points higher right
so is this information relevant well
maybe as we get closer down to 40 uh to
57 and a quarter it is but who knows
maybe that gets pulled we don't know
right that's the problem when you're
looking at depth of Market the orders go
in orders go out they're always people
adding and and removing orders from the
market whereas what trades on a
footprint chart is the actual volume and
that's significant because people are
committed to a
position right whether they're long or
short they have interest in a price
level so this is telling me there's only
two people interested in buying up here
that and if there's just only or it
could be one person bought two contracts
but whoever traded here the was only two
contracts okay and you know other
Traders will say no you know you got to
look at the depth of Market the the heat
map or book map you see down here at
4945 there's 453 on the bid yeah that's
nice information to no problem is we're
trading 4960 how can I use this
information based off of where we're
trading um do we even you know last time
we're at
4945 was you know at
10:00 this information was was useful
here noticing that there's a big bid
coming in okay fine you had a big bid
here that got pulled later um so I'm not
saying that you know a book map or a
heat map is is useless there are very
practical uses for it but the way that
I've always traded with order flow and
this goes back to when um I left the
trading floor in the early 90s to go
trading upstairs on the Globex we called
the Globex desk because that's where all
the machines were you had see me had
Globex uh Board of Trade had project a
NX
and comix had the system called access
and you know I'd be staring at the price
ladder all night long you know from
10:30 at night until 8:15 in the morning
when S&P is closed there were no minis
where traded Around the Clock it was
still just
snps then then the pit would open at at
at
8:30 so anyway I digressed there a
little bit but um you know that's why I
get more value and I think a lot of
Traders get a lot of value from a
footprint as opposed to looking at a
dome now the problem is if you're
looking at multiple markets right if
you're staring at one market it's easy
to see that but now nowadays we all got
multiple screens you know even my laptop
I could hook up multiple screens to a
laptop um and all these desktops right
we we all got big monitors and you were
watching multiple markets at once so you
want to be able to identify these areas
of Market exhaustion price exhaustion if
you will you know areas where Traders
are no longer interested by and how are
they how do we know they're no longer
interested by looking at the volume the
lack of volume thereof okay so again
this was one of the original tools when
I released the order flows Trader um you
know 10 years ago now we've got about 15
and and we're working on adding you know
another big group to the the next
upgrade but here exhaustion prints
okay so to see it on the chart now
there's two ways we'll start with fixed
and until tested and you could adjust
the level that you want I like um
looking at three so it tells me you know
three contracts some people I know like
to just look for markets where they
trade just one contract okay and some
people like to look at nine or
10 and you could adjust that here so
we'll keep it at three hit apply okay
now it's fixed okay so if it's both
bullish it's going to be green color if
it's bearish it's going to be red color
okay and you know why because you know
when you think something's bearish you
think red right when something's bullish
you think uh green green means buy or
you could some people like to use blue
you can see it right here okay
two and it's highlighted okay and that's
important for when you're looking at
multiple markets you want to see things
right away that's why we highlight it
and we also put this little uh
down triangle if it was bullish it would
be a green up triangle below the bar but
again you know some people think well
you know that's kind of hard to see
that's why we have the option to draw it
out until tested and what until tested
means it's going to draw out that zone
until price comes back and tests it okay
because often times when you see
exhaustion prints in the market the
market can run quickly from them now not
all the time sometimes you know Market
can go sideways right some you have
bullish order flow but no continuation
and the market goes sideways but when
you got bearish order flow or bullish
order flow and you do have
continuation you do have continued
bearish orderflow coming after a bearish
exhaustion print like you have here
right you got nice stacked selling
imbalance got actually six selling IM
balances in the next bar you know that
this Market is probably going to drop
further you can see two here right this
green line is
actually an exhaustion print from way
earlier from the previous day because
this is the low for the day you can see
it in here on this move down exhaustion
print exhaustion print exhaustion print
all as the market is dropping okay A
little bullish one here um this was at
8:30 just after the cash opened and you
know it's it's something that's stupidly
simple to see you don't need to be be a
math PhD to understand this it's just
telling you Traders aren't interested at
this price anymore and if you know that
that's information that you can take and
and go trade with and what I love about
orderflow right it's very robust
and what works in one market should work
in another market right I I get
frustrated when I see people saying I
got an e- mini system or I got a NASDAQ
system and it only works in that one
market right really it should be
transferable to other markets to be
legitimate and long lasting
so um um you know take go look at bonds
real quick
here okay so bonds right bonds is a bit
different than snps it's a little bit
slower you don't you know if you're on a
Time based chart you don't get a lot of
um price movement sometimes in one
minute sometimes it's just going to
trade the bid in the offer or it can
trade just one price and so honestly
looking at a one minute chart is a
little bit difficult you just don't have
that information that you'd like to see
me personally like to use a range-based
chart on um interest rates and you can
see here right exhaustion print
two three right barish bearish you know
this is when we had
some uh volatility in the market you can
see Market is moving very fast this is 9
minutes yeah how many bars formed in the
first 10 seconds you see on this move
down exhaustion print exhaustion print
exhaustion print one as the Market's
going up till 9 o' this morning um this
is 9 o'cl so
again you could adjust it whatever level
you want you know if you want to use one
or two or three or even um 10 depending
on the market that you're trading okay I
mean I I could set this to
nine as you know bonds you know here is
28 1 6
6 okay you see a six down here right now
uh not right now but about uh 20 minutes
ago
okay so again it's something that is
very useful for Traders to look at right
you don't need to go blind watching a
dome trade you know because to be honest
you know if you're watching a dome and a
lot of most markets it's pretty stable I
mean if I was looking at bonds you
know, 983 on the bid 1,000 below it 280
800 a th000 okay but if really what
you're looking at is what the volume is
that going through you don't need to
understand all this volume that's going
through all you got to do is just watch
How It's accumulating on the chart right
where it's printing on the bid on the
offer is the bar up or down okay what's
doing on the bottom of a bar or at the
top of a bar right watch the edges of
the
bars all right guys so I'm going to end
that video there um so thanks for
watching my video on on one of my
favorite trade setups which is um
exhaustion prints I hope you find this
tip helpful for your understanding of
orderflow and let me know what you like
to discuss next by leaving a comment in
the comment section below so if you
haven't already be sure to hit that uh
like button and subscribe to my channel
so you don't miss any more of these uh
videos so thanks so much for watching
and being a part of my community your
support is appreciated so I'll see you
guys on the next video okay
byebye